all right and Welcome to our
information session
how to build a cloud a Computing career
with Caltech Center for technology and
management education
to keep an eye out for our speaker who
should be joining us shortly
um we're expecting
Matthew David to join us but I'll tell
you about the agenda
we're going to ask a few questions along
the way about you but we'll be talking
about cloud computing careers and then
we'll go into how Caltech ctme can help
with that
um learner outcomes enrollment steps
take some of your questions my name is
Stuart Creek I'm a marketing manager
here at simply learn
and
hoping to be joined by Matthew David who
is a cloud computing expert with
Accenture Corporation one of our senior
instructors who'll be standing in for
Mike Ash today
I'm hoping that he'll be arriving
shortly
Matthew David is a digital leader with
Accenture Cloud devops Ai and blockchain
he's published author of 13 books
joining us right now
we'll be going into the presentation
but before we get started as Matthew
gets online
we're going to talk a bit up front about
the careers available
uh practitioners in cloud computing
cloud computing is one of the critical
Technologies shaping our world today
and it
had been assuming greater and greater
importance over the last
decade and a half
and then the pandemic hit
and we all went into lockdown we had to
work from home we had to do non-contact
transactions online with people
supplying us things
very difficult to do things in the
non-digital domain
so
cloud computing became essential it's
also the backbone of
mobile computing
so as more and more of Our Lives move on
to our handheld device
I think we're having some network issues
folks so which people us do it to rejoin
us hopefully he can join us here very
quickly
oh
Matthew you can unmute yourself
it's good to see you again
yes and I apologize to everybody on this
webinar because my computer rebooted
itself
on its own
I I had that happen uh 30 seconds before
I was supposed to join uh I I don't know
what it is about Microsoft sending out
that worldwide signal but I apologize
again I was in the middle of presenting
and I'm going to basically just
um
go back to that
hold on a second as I go back to
live show
we'll share that
all right
so Matthew I was about to um I don't
know whether our audience heard any of
what I was saying
sorry
about that
there we go
so I was talking about the cloud as the
background of the digital economy can
you um
you're
a sort of leader at Accenture you're an
expert in Cloud blockchain AI
all the emerging Technologies can you
tell us about how how cloud has
transformed our world in the last
decade and also most specifically since
the pandemic
so uh so that so some good scenarios
there so let me kind of break it down
into three key categories uh one is on
opportunity the second is acceleration
and three is uh being a customer
accessibility
uh so we start with the first one
opportunity
um with the with Cloud we have this
unique opportunity where we have for the
first time uh foreign
compute ability so uh anything you want
to do from a digital point of view uh
can be accomplished
um and more importantly uh unlike uh in
previous uh generational changes in
technology so we looked at you know the
client server to web to mobile and to
where we are now with cloud
previously there was a significant
barrier to entry and so if you wanted to
be able to come in and adopt and take um
advantage of the new opportunities that
are available you had to invest
um and you know that number was
typically at least a hundred thousand
and could be up much north of that with
Cloud you can actually uh start
investing in Solutions and start
Building Solutions immediately with no
cost
um and the ability to accelerate your
teams is just phenomenal so let me just
give you an example
um I was working with a team a couple of
years ago and we wanted to be able to
um really kind of better analyze the
data that we were receiving from from
vehicles and we were managing fleet
vehicles and we wanted to be able to
manage the data more effectively so we
actually built the whole solution for
managing that in the cloud and and the
reason why we wanted to do that is that
um we knew that we had at the time that
the client had invested in our work and
we wanted to be able to show to them at
very little cost uh what the potential
was and we were able to put together a
solution that actually showed that the
tracking and the routing
um of the vehicles in their Fleet and
more importantly by using AI tools we
were able to then show them how they
could optimize their Fleet now I I will
pause and say that it was a very basic
example we didn't go into too much depth
but we were able to have it up and
running as a real solution not a fake
and click solution but a real solution
um in four weeks and I only had two
people working on that so it was a
really a great opportunity to be able to
get in at a very low cost so that's
that's one area the second is uh just
the ability to take advantage of this
significant solutions that are coming
out so when I think cloud
um you know typically you think uh
compute you think data storage but now
you have to start thinking uh AI
um uh analytics
um uh additional services and uh and uh
recently uh AWS uh presented
um and reignite uh their I think that
was like two weeks ago and they had
their annual conference just a
phenomenal event
um a slew of new technologies so if you
are in the AWS environment just you've
now got access to all these new
technologies you don't have to worry
about finding a server to install the
software you don't have to worry about
having somebody skilled in your
organization to manage that software uh
if you are working in an area that's
brand new to you like uh and I'll give
an example iot internet things and you
want to put sensors on a device on a
system and then you want to be able to
track that well building the actual
device is only really one of the key uh
areas that of building a iot solution
you need to have the device you need to
have the services and then you need to
have the software uh or AWS you know
they just have available to you all of
those uh services and softwares that you
can just plug and play and you can build
and be accelerating quickly
um and the third is on customers so I'm
going to use a a small example here but
it's one I think can relate to everybody
uh my my wife
uh she wants to um she got a qriket
machine she loves uh crafting and she
got a qriket machine and she wanted to
be able to
um build custom items and then sell them
and so I said well let's let's just just
create a business for you uh it took uh
well what was great is my wife is not
very technically Savvy I I I know
everything you know everything but I
know a lot about computers and and she's
the opposite and that's why I love her
so much uh and uh so she um actually
went out and she spent an afternoon
researching one afternoon uh somebody
who is not technically Savvy gets very
intimidated with tools like Excel she
created a website she created an
e-commerce site um she was able to uh
Reach Out build a customer list and uh
Drive marketing uh to her customers and
now she has a map on
um in her craft room
um of of the world which with ends all
over it of customers that she has
reached out and connected with that
previous to the cloud would not have
been able to do which is generated a new
Revenue stream
that's only been made available because
of the cloud and those are three key
areas
um that the cloud offers and it just
keeps expanding the in the opportunity
so
um for myself personally if you are an
entrepreneur or you are someone that is
looking to provide innovation in your
organization the cloud is where that's
going to happen
that makes perfect sense I'm glad you
mentioned iot I was going to bring that
up but that's
you know we're we're all kind of even
before the the buzzword iot became
popular
um
started finding out that we were all
part of a
sort of iot network because we all had
that thing in our hands called the
smartphone
and the original iot device yes exactly
and it's
the the i in iot is Internet of Things
the it's all connected
through cloud-based Communications and
cloud-based systems
um even though the
Last Leg of that is through the
cellular network but
all of the back end as you mentioned
the transformative aspect of the cloud
isn't necessarily about the fact that it
interconnects systems but it the fact
that it makes resources available
from providers
for as you said infinite computing power
at your fingertips and it's storage at
your fingertips
um what infinite meaning whatever you
can afford to pay for so
this is uh but it's it's what's what's
interesting is that the the price for
cloud services uh continues to keep
coming down I mean we have more law for
compute
um and you know the pricing model really
follows that
um I was talking to a friend of mine and
he is
um I I count uh lead at AWS and he said
that you know they believe that the uh
the the total addressable market for
cloud is over a trillion dollars
um which about 10 has been captured
right now I mean it's just it is
phenomenal how much
um uh opportunity can be generated
because of the ground yeah
um
Computing skills so we talk about
careers
there's a lot of different career paths
and yes
I'm going to tell a small anecdote that
relates to how pervasive
career paths are in terms of you know
where you can find them and
how
fast they're growing
um
20 odd years ago I went on a vacation
with my family to the Columbia River
Gorge of Oregon which is a beautiful
beautiful location
amazing geology
great huge wide river and we stopped at
the
Bonneville power Dam
which is a major hydroelectric
generation
am that dates back to the 1930s or so
and uh
we stopped at a small town called The
Dalles
in Oregon
um
a few years after that visit
I found out that Google
that opened the data center in the Dells
which is hardly a DOT on the map or it
had hardly been a DOT on the map but the
reason they opened the data center there
is because
there's a river for coolingly systems
and there's a power dam for power there
server and and storage Farms so yep
these types of things pop up all over
the world and
the the job opportunities are unlimited
whether you want to work Hands-On in a
physical environment or whether you want
to work
um in a virtual environment remotely so
can you talk about you know
from your perspective what are some of
the the key
positions or career paths that
involved with cloud computing today gosh
um
hey gosh uh well so let me let me start
uh with uh an additional story um
because that was an absolutely
fascinating story
um but this is one that came from
Business Insider just this week uh as we
all keep hearing where we're supposedly
uh going into a global recession
there's a lot of leading indicators for
that to happen in 2023.
um I I but what's interesting the the
article said that uh while we we may be
moving into that uh the uh job market
isn't probably going to change much um
and what that means is that the desire
to have highly skilled people brought
into the workforce
is actually only increasing
um and I can tell you from my own
experience and I manage hundreds of
people uh that uh Cloud skill sets um
are extremely important and as we look
at Cloud skill sets there's a number of
key things that I'm looking for uh first
of all um uh I think everybody should
take the time to take the the foundation
level
um certification for either AWS Azure or
Google Cloud platform and those are the
the big three but there are others like
sap and IBM that are also have their own
skill sets but I would take at a minimum
get at least one of those as a
foundational
um I I myself took the AWS foundational
um certification a couple of years ago
the reality is is that the foundational
skills for one are very similar to the
foundational skills for the other
um major platform providers so that
that's one thing because that helps you
credentialize yourself when you're
having a conversation or applying for a
role in a company
um once you've credentialized yourselves
and you have your foot in the door and
you're having a conversation what you
won't be able to do is identify uh what
other parts that are driving uh
Innovation within an organization is it
cost savings which is very important uh
is it a new Revenue generation is it a
better understanding of customers is
improving the the supply lines
um and from there you can now start
making decisions on what do you want to
do with your career within an
organization and
um what I found is that uh there is if
we look at a model such as scaled agile
which is a uh emerging as one of the the
leading uh leans from like delivery
models and if you haven't had a chance I
would certainly take the opportunity to
go out and look at the scaled agile
framework uh it's a open source solution
but absolutely fantastic lots of great
details there
um and if you go through that there's
lots of different skill sets that are
needed and all of them are applicable
for the cloud it is a model that is
designed for a modern way of software
delivery and if you are doing software
delivery and or any really kind of
digital engagement uh in 2022 and 2023
you need to have the plan and so there
are lots of different skill sets in
there and we've got some of them on the
slide here from cloud architect and
Cloud Engineers we have uh one of the
things that I like about a cloud
developer is not only can you harness
your existing developer skill sets but
you can also take advantage of uh
serverless skill sets and such is our
building functions such as Lambda using
Lambda and AWS or functions in aw in a
sorry Azure or gcp which is just
fantastic from a data side there's just
tremendous amount of opportunities
um
the cloud tools the cloud providers are
very mature when it comes to data
management so being able to Define data
Lake being able to apply analytics and
being able to use AI those are critical
within the ability to be successful in
the cloud and then obviously security is
a foundational layer below that one one
thing that's interesting about security
is that
um it it's it's hard to get the
certification and security and and it's
intentionally hard but once you have it
it's it's almost Limitless the the
ability for you to be successful I've
I've got several friends uh who um uh
you know in their mid-30s uh were
already schizos of organizations simply
because the ability to get someone who
has both management skills and the
technical skills extremely rare and so
it just opens up the opportunity for you
to grow your career rapidly within an
organization
so anyway you know me I can go on all
that well but no but that's extremely
helpful I mean and you you point out an
important aspect which is
that the cloud is a kind of a baseline
or a foundation for some of the other
things that you can pursue within
technology so for example
and devops or software development and
deployment continuous integration
continuous deployment can only happen
when you have
the the cloud if you're if you're
talking about
devops for any type of publicly
available or consumer-based application
or service
you have to have the cloud to be able to
to distribute that so
um again you're probably using the cloud
internally
um with respect to coordinating
different development teams and
across different geolocations so
I'm going to talk to a number of
organizations whether they're
Regional Bank for example one of the one
of the
Executives there was talking about how
she works with her development teams
around the world
um you wouldn't think it necessarily A
Regional Bank would have that many
different
locations
um but she works with development teams
in
many countries and coordinates all of
that and it's only possible through the
cloud I mean
early on in the pandemic I heard a
venture capital executive who said you
know if they told us that we would have
to move everybody to work from home we
would have told management that will
take 10 million dollars in six months
when it happened it took three days with
no budget
and um
on the one hand that means the cloud was
the enabling technology that that
happened but the other aspect of that is
that opens up a whole new set of
opportunities for people who have those
skills because for example
um now all these people are working from
home uh outside of the Four Walls of
their organization
the cloud security becomes Paramount for
that organ
something that they have to go back now
and retrofit into their operations so
people with those kinds of skills are in
extremely high demand and as you said
we may be going into a secession but one
of the key factors in a recession is the
people who have particular skill sets
that allow companies to be more
efficient and and more survivable
through economic hard times are still in
demand so yeah absolutely you talked
about
I mean some of the things that
are technical skills
the kinds of things that people need to
use or do in their day-to-day operations
we put a few of these on the slide can
you
um you comment on some of these and and
how they
impact somebody's uh day-to-day work in
Cloud yeah
so so what's what's interesting um with
the skills that we're that we need for
the cloud is that um what I what I've
I've been in the industry now for gosh
um well more than five years
um and what I'm finding is that the more
things change the more things stay the
same
um and so the the needs that we have as
we're going through and building out
Solutions
um those needs haven't changed
um but uh what has changed is the
ability to adapt and embrace the the
tools that allow you to fulfill the need
so I'm going to use uh testing as one of
those so with performance testing
um you know it used to be I mean I
remember this was uh gosh 20 years ago
we actually bought a separate server
um and then had to artificially bombard
the server with a hundred thousand users
and it took us about two weeks to
actually do the whole process uh now at
anyone on my team uh we would go out and
we would leverage a service that allows
us to simulate that and we would do it
in an afternoon and we just wouldn't
think twice about it and we would then
incorporate that impact
um those results uh into our pipeline so
each time we roll out a solution we're
automatically doing a load testing and
and this is where uh the cloud really
comes into play I was talking to one of
my clients uh gosh it was just yesterday
actually and we were talking about
citizen developer Solutions and so
um Microsoft's Power Platform is a
leading example of that but there is
honeycoat from AWS and these are all
really just drag and drop tools and we
were doing an assessment on the impact
of system developer self solutions that
are built by people who are not
programmers uh within uh clients
organization and I had Disaster Recovery
as one of the key points on there and
they said why do you even have disaster
recovery on here because you know
they're the the person's you're just
dragging and dropping I said yeah but
the thing that you want to look for is
that that drag and drop interface is it
being managed within a framework and is
that framework have Disaster Recovery uh
security and the requirements that it
puts in place to ensure that the person
building the solution is doing it in a
protective environment and so we have to
have those kind of skills to be able to
adapt to the new way of working is is
really critical and that's really going
to become something that
um as a as an engineer as you enter into
this Market or you continue to grow your
career in this market it's taking your
skill set and then adapting it um so for
instance you know I'm fully expecting
right 2023 to be the year of expanded
reality we already have tools from a
matter for augmented reality which are
are interesting copies I wouldn't say
it's a business but there's a lot of
speculation that the apple is going to
enter the market next year Apple only
brings out a product when they know that
they can have significant impact on
their on a market and we're talking like
being able to have billions of units of
sold
um and so when that happens that will
open up a whole new way of computing
um but what happens with every time we
get a new way of computing is we take
our existing ways of computing and we
adapt our skill sets um so that's
something that as we look to build on
your base skills that you're learning
here as a practitioner also keep in mind
how you can adapt those skill sets for
new technologies and ways of working AI
being another example that is is going
to continue to rapidly and radically
change how we work and interface within
our own organizations
and I think
to the the theme of this of this session
I mean you build a cloud computing
career step by step by
building your foundation and then adding
on overtime and through lifelong
learning
um
other tools that that may seem like
they're unrelated but are actually very
important so for AI or
um devops are understanding
the use of virtual reality or augmented
reality and those types of things that
depending on who you're working for and
what you're doing those things are going
to become more important
additional skills that you want to add
to move yourself up that that career
path so yeah
so we've talked about the the careers in
cloud computing I want to ask the
audience a bold question if I may and
um
looking for the poll questions
oh I know what happened I got rebooted
allow me to bring up the poll question
separately here
very sad that uh
in Microsoft did that to me in the
middle of
presentation but um
start off with
question number one which is
what is stopping you
to share the screen here
so you can see that but if you're on
WebEx here with us you see the widget
asking you this question
if you
multiple time to um
answer that
and then really you can
you can answer with one two three or all
four of these whatever these factors are
that are affecting your decision What
stopped you from getting into a program
to certify yourself in cloud computing
and start that launch that career that
you're looking to have
and here is the poll result
the the most uh popular answer 64 of the
audience almost two-thirds that they
don't feel they would end up with
practical experience that they could
show off to a potential employer
confidently State yes I have these
skills and here is how I've demonstrated
that
um and then fitting it into your work
schedule is the next most
popular answer in this poll so
let's talk about some of those factors
in the context of the cloud competing
boot camp from Caltech
um
one of the things that relates to
building your career is building that
Foundation
and the comprehensive curriculum
the boot camp gives you the foundation
starting with the basic understanding of
cloud computing and moving up through
the skill set so that you end up through
using integrated Labs through Hands-On
exercises and
doing projects you end up with a
portfolio of experience that you can
show off
to potential employers
and more importantly that you have the
confidence
that you've used those skills use those
tools and can use them whenever called
upon in career it's all delivered online
it's all delivered through online
virtual learning management system I
shouldn't say virtual learning
management system
um
let me ask you will be able to show us
some of that in a bit but this gives you
the chance to take your weekly classes
the only part of the program that's
scheduled at a specific time are the
weekly live classes with your instructor
where you're on
virtual
classroom with
the instructor live taking you through
the material taking you through the
exercises
interacting with you taking your
questions live giving you a chance to
interact with the other people in the
class
the that's very different from just a
self-paced video approach
to certification or education this is a
real Boot Camp style approach and
in between the weekly classes you have
the option to do your homework your
projects at any time during the week 24
7.
have support where you can reach out
email your instructor for an answer the
next day or go out to your peers to the
community bulletin board
for more real time or reach out to the
24 7 support staff
uh from Simply learn who will support
your questions about the subject matter
or about the platform itself and so it's
it's flexible enough that you can do it
within pretty much any lifestyle
um
again you have to commit to showing up
to those live classes weekly and doing
the work in between but it's only about
a 10 to 15 hour a week commitment over
the six months so
um
imminently doable for pretty much anyone
the working professional yeah absolutely
absolutely
um at the end of the process you've got
certification
certificate I should say from
Caltech that shows that you have
completed the Caltech ctme boot camp
that you have completed all the core
courses and demonstrated proficiency and
all the skills
that you've learned
you've completed a Capstone project as
part of this that is
really
um
significant industry-based project where
you're given a problem that you would be
asked to solve if you were working in
industry and you provide a solution it's
a three to four week process and I'll
talk about that more later
um if you happen to be in uh
job that requires
either uh government
um
professional licensure or have to
provide your employer evidence of
ongoing learning
Caltech will issue you up to 15
continuing education units
uh so that that's a plot oops sorry I
didn't mean to go back
um
and you get membership the Celtic ctme
Circle so you become part of an alumni
association of people who have taken
this type of training
um across many different disciplines and
sectors uh through Caltech ctme that's
great for lifelong industry career
networking
um you'll get recognized to the
convocation or the program director will
be calling your name out and you'll be
able to invite your friends and family
to join you online for that
and
one of the key aspects is career
assistance through simply learning and I
will describe that in more detail but um
we're going to go into the details of
the curriculum in a bit but I want to
mention Caltech um
caltex vtme is the professional
management
technology education branch of Caltech
Caltech is 130 year old Institution
um pretty much everybody at least in the
United States is familiar with the Big
Bang Theory sitcom on CBS that
the set at Caltech because they wanted
to um
portray the brightest people who might
not be
so well adapted to uh social skills but
they decided the the one place in the
world where
the most
brilliant people would be gathered
together as Caltech which is basically
true it's the home alma mater of a
number of Nobel Prize winners people who
did their research at Caltech to
Kingdom the Noble Prize people who won
the Nobel Prize and then came to Caltech
to continue their research and to
lecture to graduate students so it
consistently reacts consistently can
consistently ranks in the top five
universities worldwide
of all universities
so people recognize the name Caltech on
CV on your resume and it's definitely
a feather in your cap as they used to
say to have that
um
so the eligibility for this
boot camp
I mean it's kind of amazing Matthew in
the sense that this is a wide open
program it's available pretty much
anybody
um and it
that's a testament to How It prepares
you from the ground up right
so you can be from a non-programming
background you do not have to have a
part a particular programming language
knowledge or programming skills
um you'll get that in the
uh program itself the high school
diploma
18 years of age
and
you don't need to have work experience
so this is something that can
do at any point in your career from the
very beginning on up to you know
very senior
person in in the industry who wants to
Pivot into cloud computing or want to
add cloud computing to their skill set
you don't have to feel like you're
coming from
non-technical background that it's a
limitation and you don't have to feel
like that if you're coming from a
technical background that you're not
going to get useful information here
on
for a wide spectrum of the audience
so I will ask a second question if I may
this question is pretty straightforward
I know that there's no work experience
required but just to get a feeling from
the audience how much experience do you
have in the work course and this doesn't
mean in cloud computing the students
just work experience
it's open for another 10 seconds or so
close the pole in just a few seconds
here
watch the answers roll in
and this is pretty cool
um
look at the answers here we have a
a fairly seasoned audience here half of
the audience of more than 10 years of
experience
and that's a
really interesting result often we see
that it's bimodal where there's a lot of
people with
um very little experience in the number
of people with more than 10 years but in
this case today's audience is heavily
weighted towards experienced folks so
we'll be talking about how this program
also benefits you even though the
prerequisites are are so open
and I'm gonna at this point I'm going to
let um
Matthew talk about these points while he
demonstrates the learning management
system if you're prepared to do that
Matthew
well unfortunately I just went in and I
don't have access uh to the LMS
um
[Laughter]
so we can talk about these
um these items uh you know so let's just
kind of go through these uh real quickly
and then I'll bring back to you
um but this is a you know you manage
your curriculum and
um you are going to be all you are going
to be held to is delivering a specific
key uh projects and tasks
um at key points uh during uh the
program itself
for people like uh yourself and myself
where we have busy lives with kids and
juggling a a career it's really ideal
because you can come in and as you need
and I find weekends work very well for
me uh to be able to come in
um we do however also have live virtual
classrooms um and this is a unique
differentiator that simply learned us
that other training organizations uh
that are online simply don't do which is
to have the ability to talk directly
with a knowledgeable faculty member uh
who can then ask answer your questions
directly so you really do get the
benefit of both having uh designing your
time frame by yourself and having the
ability to talk to a faculty member ah
uh here we go
um and uh so uh
um really the the whole work then ends
up um being driven towards uh having
uh we're just waiting for this to come
up uh we're having this uh driven
towards uh your Capstone project and
this is one that you'll uh develop to be
able to help diff um clearly um
illustrate uh the knowledge that you
have gained and the ability for you to
be a practice leader in this space uh
and uh but what's really a great benefit
is that as you're going through there's
no black hole on um how successful
you're being uh you'll actually see that
there's a progress indicator that shows
how far you're moving forward and really
gives you that momentum to be able to
keep advancing and building up on your
skill set so you are driving towards a
specific goal
um and then as Stuart mentioned there's
a lot of support tools and your uh your
instructors really want your key support
tools um but your fellow students as
well will also be a strong support tool
from being able to bounce ideas but then
outside of that you have a lot of
resourcing tools that will be able to re
and that you can actually take advantage
of virtually to be successful as you
build out your skill set and then
Advance your career with uh into the
cloud
so Stuart I'm going to hand it back to
you
okay and I'm back
so
how the program builds your your cloud
computing skills step by step
it's designed as a staircase find start
with the foundation and move you up
uh stepwise through the set of courses
in the learning management system as you
complete each course
you unlock the next one the the
orientation session of course is just
getting you settled into the learning
management system uh giving you a set of
expectations for what the curriculum
will be what your time demands will be
and once you finish that you can begin
with the Cloud's fundamentals course for
AWS notice that
this program starts with AWS Cloud
fundamentals takes you then to designing
applications and architectures
WS platform then moves you into Azure
Cloud fundamental and doing similar
things on in the Azure environment so
that you end up with some experience on
both the two major platforms for cloud
computing between them they have
dominating percentage of the the cloud
computing Market
um
so you are learning how to build
cloud computing architectures structures
applications
um how to manage the environment your
organization and then
move into infrastructure Solutions on
Azure to get you a bit more extensive
experience in building out the kind of
solution that you're going to develop
for your Capstone project finally that
Capstone project is a three to four week
effort where you're taking a
industry-based problem
and being asked to solve it with your
own solution under the mentorship of
your instructor
and that becomes your final project and
e to uh he awarded the the final
certificate along the way you can take
at your discretion the
academic master classes from the Caltech
dtme instructors
who do monthly lectures
again this is an elective but it's no
additional cost so you can take those as
as you see fit and if you have the time
for
the
um
Matthew can you comment on the structure
of the the
curriculum and how that
works for the advantage of the of the
learners
so I think really that the fundamental
Advantage is just the the Practical uh
focus of the curriculum it is really
built on uh solutions that you will
actually build in the real world
um uh it's it's
um designed by people who uh work and
live with cloud services within
Enterprises
um and is based around their own
experiences and so as you go through the
curriculum and particularly as you go
through the cap Stones
um you'll be building out solutions that
are practical examples of what you will
build when you actually enter the
workforce and this is an advantage um
when you're talking to people that are
hiring out in the market is that you can
actually say look I have done this and I
have evidence to show that I've done
this work
um and I can tell you as someone who
hires a lot of people each year for me
having someone who comes in and can talk
to to the the challenges and the ability
to step through a problem using cloud
services has much more value to me than
someone who says well I read a book on
it so this is where the advantage really
comes in when you're going through this
program is that you open up the door for
a future career
thank you
the program also gives you
not just exposure to but practical
experience with a whole variety of
different tools and platforms
so you're going to use a suite of
different tools from Amazon for AWS
you're going to use a suite of different
tools from Microsoft for azure
you're going to use other tools
learning about things like Docker
kubernetes that type of thing
for containerization other tools that
are important in cloud computing and at
the end of this process when you put
these on your resume it's not just
I've heard of this buzzword it's I have
experience that I can I show you the
example of where I use this in one of my
projects so you have the the confidence
to be able to say
that um
have these skills you've used these
tools you can demonstrate that and
they're they're actually part of your
toolkit and not just a collection of
buzzwords
but that's an important fact for
employers to know right Matthew yeah it
really is it really is yeah
um
so we've mentioned it several times but
the Capstone project is also one of the
differentiators of this boot camp so the
Capstone project
as I mentioned lets you pick out
something that has
real world impact some type of problem
that you might very well be assigned by
your employer
and you're working in this field
then you have to design and Implement
just to talk about or describe but
implement the solution to that problem
do that over a three to four week period
you do that by Under the mentorship of
an instructor by meeting with them
weekly to review your progress make sure
that you're not going down any
dead ends or rabbit holes and
you end up with a project that number
one is evaluated as
proof of your good ability to be awarded
the final certificate in the program
but number two is part of your permanent
portfolio
that you can show off
to potential employers during the
interviewing and reviewing process
um
and
that demonstrates that you have
real experience
with cloud computing tools
platforms
but we think that this is one of the
most important aspects of the program
yeah I would absolutely agree
um
the program is under the direction of
the Caltech ctme program director is
Rick Hefner who's been in academics and
in industry for over 40 years
runs the Caltech ctme Center for ltech
and it's also under the direction of
John wetch who is the cloud computing uh
technology program director for ctme so
these folks oversee the curriculum they
oversee the delivery uh to make sure
that it meets ctme standards Caltech
standards and
um
they assign the instructors who do the
master classes so
we're very proud to be
working with Caltech
um you can look at learner profiles by
industry people get assigned
this boot camp by their employers or
they come from different companies on
their own and so you will be
um
in a cohort with people from a wide
variety of backgrounds Industries
companies it's great for networking in
that respect but it's important to know
that
uh you won't just be talking to people
from the information technology or
software Industries talking to people
from natural sector from the industrial
sector from the e-commerce sector from
just a wide range as College Computing
potentially
spans all Industries in international
companies
and
the career assistance
additional part of the program
so that at the end of the six months of
the boot camp when you've got the
certificate
we actually continue to help you for an
additional six months in your job search
so if you are taking this program to
launch a new career in cloud computing
as opposed to gaining the skill set to
use in your current employer
um
this aspect is very very helpful we talk
about aspect the access to expert
webinars which are part of our ongoing
continuing education effort we talk
about career events with industry
leaders
um
there's also the portfolio that you
build up
Capstone and all the other projects you
do in the program
but the job assistance Services
specifically
center around several
services that we provide with our
partner Talent Inc United States and
this is available to to uh
Learners in the US only and
unfortunately not to folks who would be
enrolling from outside the U.S but
the access to the job portal the
talenting which is resume rabbit is uh
great it has a set of jobs that are
exclusive to them and
that's
we think that's an important part of the
program but there are
other job boards indeed and Glassdoor
and dice and all that there's lots and
lots of jobs that you'll be able to
apply to the job portal through Talent
Inc uh gives you better positioning as
part of this program
the more important aspects in my opinion
are the resume review and rewrite
service and the one-on-one interview
service the resume review and rewrite is
important because in today's day and age
resumes
don't go straight to human eyes they
don't go right onto Matthew's desk
before they get to Matthew at Accenture
for example they will go through an
automated tracking system and an AI bot
will evaluate it so
what's your experience in
in that uh as an employer Matthew so
um so you're absolutely right they go
through an AI machine first and uh um
you know personally
um I was
um uh the the role I have right now
um uh my resume was initially rejected
by an AI Bots and it was only because
um a Savvy uh recruiter actually dug
through and found my resume uh that I
ended up being interviewed and now have
you know I'm entering my fifth year here
at Accenture
um I can tell you that's very important
and companies like Talent Inc
um it's it really is
um when I uh entered the uh the job
market after many years of not being in
it
um about uh five and a half years ago I
actually worked with a resume writer
um but I wish I'd worked with Talent Inc
because uh not only will they help you
write and review your resume but they
can also tell you whether or not uh the
job you're applying for whether or not
you need to be changing having multiple
versions of your resume so you can be
most likely to a initially get through
the bot and then B when somebody is
reviewing your resume uh they actually
see your work and you stand out from the
crowd as somebody that should be brought
in to have either an interview over the
phone and or uh through uh Skype which
is typically the first way we do it now
um or eventually maybe in even in person
yep and and it's really an art form
um so it is absolutely it really is
that's that's a a great part of the
service
um the one-on-one interview service is
also important because
once you get past the initial screening
of the resume you need to go through the
screening process in person and there's
going to be people who are going to ask
you technical questions about cloud
computing you need to be prepared to
answer those yeah
then you're going to talk to managers
who are going to be more concerned with
how you will fit in with the team and
how you'll contribute what your worth
that work ethic is and so you need to be
prepared for those interviews as well
yeah during this process you get
one-on-one interview prep sessions you
get feedback on how to improve your
interviewing style what you need to work
on and you also get uh
some mentorship advice that to some
direction in where you should be looking
for that next job so these are extremely
valuable again this continues for six
months after you've completed received
your uh certificate from the program
from Caltech
and
it's not a guarantee of a job where it's
not a placement service it's
draw up assist service that helps you to
put your best foot forward but of course
you are then responsible for doing the
work to get that next job
um
the expert webinars that I mentioned we
bring in people from all different uh
areas different particular skill sets
Matthew's done several of these and
we'll bring in people to talk about uh
how to develop your career in a
particular field or what the Outlook is
for a particular industry we expect
Matthew to be doing one of whereas in
January about the trends coming up in
cloud and
devops and
the you can see also that we have people
who come in for example Carmen who
with the indeed and gave advice on the
ins and outs of
flying through a job board online so all
of these are happening
on a weekly basis
be able to see
these kinds of examples and pick and
choose the ones you want but they're all
free of charge
talk about the projects and within the
the program you're doing
these and other projects and these are
some of the examples of
types of projects you'll do
both during the program and as cap
stones and you're
given a scenario
and you have to develop the solution for
that scenario to according to the
specifications of the problem so you
have to build it you have to implement
it demonstrate it
um
Matthew can you comment on you know kind
of the depth of the projects that people
will be doing well I mean that as I
mentioned before they are true practical
uh references for work that you'll be
doing in the real world
um and so the the project will be one
that you can choose um but uh it will be
one that
um the instructable guide to have a real
impact on something you can bring into
the real world so uh oh gosh and of
course now I'm blanking on an example
but uh
um it you know if you were to like I
will use an example here of uh building
out a website it's you know it's it's
not just building a website but it'll be
what are the tools and services within
the cloud that you'd be leveraging to be
able to uh then take and have a
conversation with the clients and say
well this is how we test it this is how
we deployed and this is how we manage
the data of the compute environments and
these are all things that employers want
to hear
so all these examples here you see are
developing
applications that will be used either in
a business to business or business to
Consumer sets and
um so you have to go from the front end
all the way to the the back end and
Cloud backbone so
um the this is in addition to the all
the other projects that you'll be
getting throughout the
program because all of those go into
your portfolio as well and you can
somebody who talks about a specific
tooler technology that you used at some
point you'll be able to
go into the we'll get there
um
So based on what we've talked about
up to this point I'd like to know if you
might be interested in taking this
program so let me ask the whole question
I'll leave this open for another few
seconds
yeah
here is the answer
so just over three quarters of the folks
in the audience are interested in
enrolling in the program and that
very encouraging so what I'm going to do
now is share with you how to do that
very straightforward process
and the enrollment steps
start off by emailing ask us at
simplylearn.net
that's simplylearn.net will put you in
touch with our learning Consultants
we'll be able to take your initial
information and start the application
process
um
again the requirements for this are very
straightforward let me uh
it really is a very easy process
and then
once we've reviewed your qualifications
we'll be able to issue you an offer of
admission
and that offer of admission
takes you to
deciding to join the program the
designing the journal program
is
a commitment of nine thousand nine
hundred ninety nine dollars U.S
you can Finance it interest free
as low as 880 a month
um and
you can ask your employer about tuition
reimbursement if this is something that
you're doing so I'm sorry something that
you're doing for your
particular employer
then your employer based on their own
policies May reimburse you for some or
all of that cost so you need to ask
about that the next cohort starts
December 29th
with the introductory session and the
classes start January 7th
I am putting into the chat right now the
email address
to see that
but I'll ask this next quick question
which is
okay
I'm sure I've got it available here
foreign
there it is
all this for that delay
so if you are interested in enrolling
is this something you want to do for
that December cohort that started is it
something you want to do maybe for one
of the ones happening uh January
February or is it something you're
looking further out
we'll always like to say this if this is
going to
transform your career in your life in a
positive way it's always worth
considering doing it sooner than later
yeah absolutely great
the show the poll result
and about 30 percent of our audience
wants to start either with that next
cohort or one soon thereafter and the
rest of you I encourage you to email us
at ask us at simplylearn.net so that you
can keep in touch with us and we can
answer any other questions you have
advise you on future program dates
that I'm going to
open it up for questions and we have a
number of them that have come in already
awesome
but put those in the Q a box if you
would please because the chat box is
kind of cluttered
um
pull up
list of questions that we already have
here okay
um I have one question from Vivek who is
an engineering leader with 15 years of
experience
and he's been moving up through
management
um
had done the AWS solution architect
associate level certificate about five
years ago
but he's now trying to understand if
this course is going to help him
um move into the the path of a solution
architect
yeah I would say that this this uh
course is really ideal for that
um you know the the certification
process is a good process
um but it is very much
um you know when you go through it it is
a multi-choice solution
um to actually get certified with each
question whereas with this program you
actually have hands-on experience
um in solving a real world problem
um and for myself uh that as you know
I'd like to see the certification but I
also really like to see uh The Real
World experience that you have
okay
um
related to that khalsad asks
the question when you're talking about
the certifications what are the ones
that you think are most important
I think getting a foundation is really
good for old people
um I I actually have that for all my
team members irrelevant of what that
career direction is and they should get
the foundation one after that once you
start specializing particularly if
you're becoming an engineer
um or someone like data then I think
it's good to get the specialist
certifications
um they they have significant value in
the market
um but again uh you know I think you
have to then balance that with practical
experience so that you can actually
demonstrate that you just you're not
just books mods on the Technologies but
you understand the challenges of
bringing those Technologies into an
organization because ultimately you're
going to hit what a wall and it's called
culture and that's why you have to
battle within your company
so Ken asks if the boot camp prepares
people for the certification exams
and I don't want to um
say that the exam fees are included in
the program I would ask that of the
folks that ask us at something like that
and ask a learning consultant if that's
correct I would do that but but the
preparation aspects
would you agree that Matthew that
taking these courses prepares you to be
ready absolutely absolutely yeah
the um
a good question here from an anonymous
uh user
who asks
how do you plan to squeeze all the AWS
Tools in a short period of time
well that's actually a really good
question and what you find is that you
start using AWS tools very quickly
um you only you can actually sit down
and I do this I have an executive
training program that I run where I'm
the executive sit down and and these are
you know direct to level and above and I
actually take them through a a simple
exercise it's an hour long where they
actually build an AI model in Microsoft
Azure and and I have a similar one for
gcp and AWS
um and uh in that hour they actually end
up using about half a dozen aw
um Azure services to build out their
solution and the idea is for them to be
able to see that when you're working
with cloud-based Services the emphasis
is on services and how rapidly you
actually will start using them and these
are now technology you don't have to
bring into your organization you can
actually leverage and accelerate your
organization by using the cloud services
that are available to you
thank you
um we had a couple questions about
what languages
are used in cloud computing and do you
know need to know HTML and those types
of things so invariably uh you
um you you end up not using languages so
um what um you you can you can
definitely program in the cloud
um and that's what Lambda comes into
play but
um for a lot of people you don't it's
it's configuration it's understanding
what the service is what is available
and how to use it and integrate it with
other services that's where the
challenges are really coming to play
okay
um we have an interesting question from
Scott who who's under the impression
that you need a comp Tia plus
certification to get any kind of job in
it no um I don't I haven't I have an
English literature degree yeah exactly
and I'm a director of cloud services so
um you don't um what you need is a
passion for learning
um because if you're going into it
um there isn't a I've learned this skill
and that's it I don't have to learn
anything else you have to have a passion
for continuous learning
um but then also a passion for
understanding how complex problems
within a business can be resolved with
technology
okay
um so we have a couple of questions
about careers one is
what are the prospects for a pressure so
if somebody's
hearing you in the industry you're very
needed so they they have never been as
good as they are right now and they're
only getting better I mean I guess we're
going into a recession and everything
but that they've never been any better
I'll give you an example so a friend of
mine
uh she uh was running
um the uh a a web development team for a
large chemicals company in North America
um and she needed a new web developer
and typically whenever she would and
this is like five six years ago whenever
she would put out a request for uh
application
um she would get you know 15 20
applicants of which she would filter it
down to about you know five or six and
she would interview the five or six
um she is now finding that when she puts
out a job
um offer puts out a job description
she's getting only one or two people
applying for those roles simply because
the market demand it exceeds the ability
for people that are skilled within that
market
um and she ended up having to give that
role to someone who actually was the
intern on her team and that intern
started at a six-figure salary
that's nice yes
um at the other end of the spectrum
Katie asks if
this is a good launching pad because we
put cloud architect as one of the career
paths on the slide and he wants and
Katie she wants to know if this is a
good program to get started on that
career path yeah absolutely
yeah it really is a sweet answer
um uh
Adnan asks which you would recommend
uh studying blockchain or cloud
computing wow and and I've written so
frame reference and and Stuart knows
this I've actually written books on both
Technologies
um and I've worked in implementing both
Technologies
um and and blockchain I think has a lot
of potential in the future
um and there are some uh practical
applications now the demand for cloud
however is you just we can't even touch
it it's just so massive
um
so
um I I would go with cloud and then so
think of it like this major in Cloud
minor in blockchain exactly yeah that
that's a a great way of putting it the
cloud computing opens up a wider uh
array of of opportunities and then
blockchain is one specialization that
you can move into that's
got a lot of as you said potential that
is just opening up
um
I want to reassure people that we have
recorded this and we will share a link
to the recording and a follow-up email
so if there's something that you answer
I went too quickly over a slide or
happened to roll my mouse
and mess it up you'll be able to go back
and review that
um
I'll just see if
so here's a very interesting question
What are the
pass fail evaluation method for the
Capstone project
and how do how does instructor decide
that it meets the criteria
I sent you a good question I don't have
a direct answer for that so maybe I we
can follow up with that yeah but
generally speaking you're given a
problem uh statement and as you're
working with your instructor
um what you have to do is finish and
demonstrate that your solution fulfills
all of the requirements of the problem
statement
um so usually there's
a lot of objective criteria does it do
this does it have this particular
function what happens if I click here
how did you use this technology
am I getting error messages or is it
working properly so that type of
evaluation
um
generally fairly objective
um the the
that I think
helps you understand the requirement you
do have to build
something that technically works
as the pro the problem statement
requires it
um
and
Peter says he's completed ccsp online
training from Simply learned with this
program
uh complement that
looking at isc2 also
I would say so yeah
um so
this
like I said it builds a whole
Suite of skills
on top of those types of
certifications just scrolling through to
see if I missed anything and
um we're at time so I would like to say
um unfortunately we can't take any more
questions I apologize if I haven't
gotten to your question uh
but you can email us if you would like
to or contact ask us something.net
and they'll be able to
either answer the question or pass it
along and with that I'm going to ask one
final poll question
for our audience
that's
oops
that's a quick question yeah exactly
good question I don't even give you a
chance to answer
um
and and again you know
wonderful thing that happened with the
here we go
with my computer rebooting at the
beginning of the session
and it threw me off so but I have the
question up now and
um if you are interested want to get
started
especially in that December cohort let
us know if you need assistance
it's open for another few seconds
all results about half the folks out
there are interested in getting
assistance which you do by
contacting us and ask us simply.net I've
got a QR code up here that will take you
to the program page you can contact uh
contact learning Consultants through
that as well
I will again throw into the chat
those links
so that they're at your fingertips
and I'll also take this opportunity to
thank Matthew very much for being so
generous with this time
always always
um and with his industry knowledge
and thank everybody who joined us this
morning for the session we hope it was
valuable and hope we can welcome you
into the Learning Community with Caltech
CT me and simply one
so that concludes our webinar for today
and thank you all again very much